all right the last time you were here we
played this game called i spy
and um i was wondering if we could do it
again let's do it okay great so
this is a game where we show
um a close-up of a celebrity's eye
makeup and then you guess who that
person is and boy did you do so well
last time no pressure want to do it
again let's do it all right this is
um if you guessed all three correctly
everyone in the audience will go home
with your new bb cream which i have
right here
and
a bb cream is so important because it
gets amazing coverage yes it's very
healthy for your skin has wonderful
properties there's an extra bee in here
it's a bbb cream
blurring
bomb it literally
boosts hydration balances your oil and
then ultimately blurs your texture so
it's literally triple threat second skin
it's great anyone can use it okay thank
you i'm such a fan of your product thank
you so this is amazing i mean maybe
unlike okay um all right let's play the
game this is exciting now all right
let's see the first photo please
oh my gosh are you serious i know that
one's hard um this person looks like
they can do makeup really well
is it
zendaya
[Applause]
she's so famous right now her her she's
seen everywhere on every carpet and she
always rocks a sickening glam i love it
okay but seriously patrick that was like
barely the corner of an eye i don't know
how you did that
but jeez and you're right i think
zendaya has the most exciting style i
actually got to go to the cfda the
council of fashion and design awards and
she was getting an achievement award and
um
i was freaking out and of course i
passed by her and i have no ability to
be cool
and i was like
you know what i said i love you i love
you i love you i love you i love you
okay so next uh up let's see the picture
please
this one's easy
really
how y'all went real easy on me go easy
on me
is that a hint
oh is it adele i think it's adult
yes
i stare at faces all freaking day i'm on
social media looking at makeup getting
in spell and adele is known for a winged
eyeliner we have an amazing winged
eyeliner called point made get your
point made yeah statement eyes it's
waterproof and she rocks rocks and
eyeliner like no other she's just so
gorgeous and she has a signature like
crease too and i'm i'm a huge a huge
huge fan of adele a signature crease see
i love that that's the eye of an artist
okay um let's see the last photo
oh my god
um this is crazy makeup
and i think award shows have crazy
makeup either at music awards
or a crazy carpet like cfda or something
i think i remember i remember this one
this is um priyanka chopra met gala
yes
there's no other way
you can wear makeup that crazy
patrick as a beauty guru like we try to
recreate looks online and we're always
like trying to recreate images and stuff
and this was definitely i mean it's such
a standout on the carpet a little a
little crazy editorial
and the lighting kind of gave it away
once again patrick three out of three
[Applause]
patrick can we please do more stuff
together let's do it like it just
forever and more and more and more and
um i will drag you out ross will judge
you you can lipstick for your life and
we can death drop
together and let's give beauty tips and
do all the things and i want to eat next
time too because i love to eat
by the way um you know it would make a
cool segment actually i'm just literally
coming up with this right now well back
in the day before there even was makeup
women would forage for their makeup so
maybe we could do like berries on cheeks
or you know like different things from
the kitchen that you could matriculate
back to ever after with the wings and
the wigs
[Music]